here's a little bit more from the daily
wire on what's going on in China Chinese
citizens are protesting the Communist
nation's strict coveted policies with at
least one demonstration turning violent
protests intensified over the weekend in
major cities across China including
Beijing Shanghai and Wuhan according to
Media reports a demonstration in
Shanghai eventually devolved into chaos
with police clashing with protesters and
deploying pepper spray the protests
emerged as a response to the zero
coveted policies imposed by the Chinese
communist government since the beginning
of the pandemic now there are
there are hundreds and hundreds Prime
probably far more than that of videos
going across mostly across Twitter right
now because Twitter is less censored
than some of the other social media
platforms because of that scary Elon
Musk guy uh of Chaos in China and people
literally locked in buildings people
begging from you from 40 floors up
begging for food little children being
separated from their parents horrible
stuff are you seeing that on CNN is
Washington Post doing much about that is
MSNBC covering that isn't that bizarre
sort of like the election stuff that's
happening down in Brazil why did
mainstream media cover that it's almost
as if they don't like when you can see
that you the people have some power and
you can organize against the powers that
be very bizarre I'm gonna have to think
about that a little bit more uh here's
some video of these coveted protests
this is Wuhan China it's actually
earlier this morning I think
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these people have had enough there's no
such thing as a zero coveted policy that
no one will get sick the virus exists in
nature it exists in the world the
communist government is using it as an
excuse to crack down on its people to
show them that they can't fight the
government to make them more dependent
on the government does it sound a little
familiar to what's going on here in
America it's just to a different degree
and then when you think about the people
that literally voted for it again a
couple weeks ago that said hey you
locked me down you didn't let me go to
work you kicked my kid out of school
sure my kids having speech delays blah
blah blah let's give you some more power
over me